aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire d'un
ami
c'est l'anniversaire de stéphane plaza
way we would i oui et on pouvait pas
rester sans rien faire alors on va
envoyer notre reporter s'acharne à le
trouver et lui apporter un gâteau donc
shaybah est allé trouver
stéphane plaza ça je bénis safer
magnifique secours tentent de faire sa
bar mitsva retirer toujours qu'on va le
mettre sur ma jambe décalage
bonsoir cyril bonsoir à tous et où ils
vous l'avez dit c'est l'anniversaire
stéphane plaza aujourd'hui il fête ses
50 ans alors comme je n'ai pas trouvé je
suis allé devant une de ces agences
peut-être on va essayer je crois qu'il a
la jambe journée sur la somalie
mais qu'est ce qui t'a pris ça à coeur
sar au caire les frères qu'est ce qui
est appris mais tu as pris l'état prix
des chaussures de marche et les
chaussures made of this way serait
touchée j'ai voulu fêter les 50 ans de
stéphane plaza
ce qui est à chauffer quitte à chauffer
pour acheter ces bouts de sa vraie c'est
vrai c'est ma mère ah ouais frère sur la
tête de ma mère avec le jeans bien serré
comme ça les buttes j'adore tu
ressembles à un de mes idoles coluche
ces jours ci oui je la donne à chaque
fois je mettrai des baskets elle était
magnifique décalage qu'il faut cela fout
bonjour alors excusez moi c'est un sport
aujourd'hui c'est les 50 ans de
de stéphane plaza est ce que par hasard
il est dans les comptes dans les coins
alors vous savez qu'aujourd'hui fête ses
50 ans donc du coup de vous ramener un
petit gars comme un boxeur est un garde
sa distance vous l'avez souhaité l
anniversaire à votre patron
ce soir ce soir et est ce qu'il est déjà
venu dans la chance mais évidemment il
était là quand il ya longtemps bon ce
que je me permets ès qualité à tout ça
et là comme par hasard un petit gâteau
sa magnifique ça s'ajuste ya une
cheville cineplex battu les mets pas
dans la tête je me permets de lui offrir
un gâteau au nom de toute l'équipe de
sécu narratif voilà c'est pour vous
c'est cadeau et bien sûr vous dites vous
me demandez une chute à montcuq plex ya
pas de problème moi je vous ai ramené
des copines
s'il vous plaît encore les moyens
d'entrer le grand cadeau on va kiffer
c'est que dès qu'il faisait ramener là
je vais ramener la guerre
[Musique]
après l'autre non mais ça ne regardait
le mac iphone et sympathique à traire et
mettez mathema mais j'adore j'adore mais
il faudra y aller
[Musique]
la loi c'est celle d'un démantèlement
social base
c'est brown
les palaces et commercy sacha un truc
comme ça c'était chez m6 qu'il fallait
faire ça devant chez m6 pourquoi il m'a
passionné